pas du tout normales a yo la tengo
première fois maintenant on avoue j pas
pendant les kings on ne bouge pas
pendant les juniors premier baiser
pendant que 12 cd lui dos et quel était
son prénom
je pars si vous me manquez il est là et
là ce soir
non sérieusement oui c'est bastia s'est
bien vite restait cinq mois ensemble
bonne réponse alors maintenant on va
passer à la première fois tous les deux
tout nu dans un lit le décollage s'est
passé bastien c'est un autre celui quel
âge
c'est bravo et ça a duré combien de
temps non non non la relation aux
relations monter des histoires
bravo vous répondez bien deux ans votre
premier casting est très attention
c'était chez filipacchi aux champs
elysées jeune et jolie première idole
première fois première fois à trois
bandes
enfin il y en a une première fois quatre
parcours premier chagrin d'amour parce
que vous n'êtes pas encore aimer
vraiment peut-être avant vous à 20h mais
c'est quoi la part ça je sais pas
premier premier joie de cabanis j'ai eu
mon meilleur copain mathieu je suis son
père médecin à wayne souvent trop le
médical datant première chose que vous
faites le matin en vous réveillant je
reste ou dit